どうもみなさんこんにちははじめんです皆さんスマホを知っていますでしょうか
スマートフォンとはなぜスマホと言われているかと言うと先進的な軽耐久法律を備えた
携帯電話の一種でございます従来の携帯電話フューチャーフォンやパソコンの機能を
取り込んでいる携帯端末されるが一時期に明確な定義は今のところないと言われており
ます日本ではスマホそのホッケーたいとも称されていますなぜ皆様細野付入ってます
けれども具体的
スマホって体じゃなくてまぁなんかあのボタンが少なくて大画面1個ついてたらなんか
スマホっぽいなっていうイメージだと思いますがスマホだけ買うんじゃなくてて芝生は
買うとフィルターケースを張ったりログをつけてるんですけどこのケースですねケース
付き合いと傷ついたりするんで付けてるんですけども多く
やっぱりなくしちゃうんですよ相変わらずなことですま
もう何回友和指令のほどなくしてきたんですね本結構なくしちゃってどうしようと思っ
てなんか動画の撮影とか静かにしなきゃいけないことが多いから基本的にマナーモード
なんですよ非常に失くしやすい
ナックススマートフォンならそもそもそもそものスマートフォン時代を行くすればいい
あってますよねあってると思いますよねもちろん合ってると思いますというわけで今回
はでね待ってスマートフォン
ほど形成ていつも大きいの取り組んだサイズから大きなスマホ決してあんまりないん
ですよ
そんなもんかはいはいはそんなもんねー
はっいま兄弟スマホケース調べたんですけどもまぁ西寧大きくてもなんかバナナケース
みたいな購入スマホっかむしろついてる大きいぐらいしかないですねツイザー
な2でしょえ実はですね僕専用のそう巨大なスマホケースと実は特別に作っていただい
ておりまして今回それが届いたという話でございますいいことでこれが俺のあたらせ
スマホケースねこれだけ大きかったらダメなんです
ことはないだろうと言うね現在的な発想だと思うよありがてそれではバックみたら
カバンになってる時ドライバーとこのついてる盾に撮っ苦痛じゃないぜドライバーも
ついてるよでこちらが俺の知る限りそしてネットで見る限りは世界最大級のその
ホッケーとになっておりま
開けてみましょう
者がいろいろデザインの中も落ちたんですけど実物見るのは本当初めてなんです
失礼します
ん
結構かっこいいとこれ
うわーっすごいすごいすごい持ってもらって結構すごいぞ
あった
うわぁ
こちらですげーなんてほれっぽい感じで作ってくださいって言ったんですけども数とか
すごいするっぽいぞたい定義でこれが世界最大けれどスロー系です今使ってるやつほぼ
一瞬のデザインというか
この何か落ちても大丈夫なやつになってますこんな感じになっております
そしてちゃんとここには肇社長のログインでございますすげー
たっけーホセさんとスマホ入れる部分もあるんですけども電源ボタンを押せないし音量
なボタンを押せないのでそこを押す用の空間だけはちゃんと開けてあります心配するの
もいれてみますか
またから出て入れるの校しかないよねちょっとすね地で外さないといけないのかなネジ
だけな人ダメ
自分いただきます
[音楽]
打っています
ok ahkah ここにそのほ入れるのか行ってみますいいねいいねー
様子できましたはいスマホが入りましたこれすごいなちゃんと写真も撮れる様に
02カメラの部分なりその穴が開いてるんですよでも普通にこうやって写真は撮れる
わけですよ
全然写真はで問題でとれますぜ全然使える愛という気でこれだけ大きなスマホケース
だったら多分なくさないと思います本当ちゃんの写真も撮れるし電源をたんだここでを
セルシオ冷房ポジションを下げたりできて写真もちゃんと撮れるので8実用性は
ちゃんとありますで落としても画面の割で心配がありませんというわけでちょっと今日
から
泳い一さんよく考えろよ絶対めんどくさいやーん
ちょっと身近見にしとこうかな一周か今日から一週間ちょっとこちらのスマホケースで
生活してみようと思いますそしてこちら
気になる値段はなんだ380,000円
me
あっはぁ
ん
4日
持って
uh
もう過ごせ